I haven't taken Tylenol every four hours, two tablets for the past year.
Is there a danger to continue this?
Yeah, there is.
Tylenol can be very dangerous to multiple metabolic pathways in the liver.
Realistically, there's statistically by their own statistics,
there's about 15,000 people a year that die
from Tylenol toxicity, and it's shuts down their liver, and they die of liver failure.
I'm not trying to scare you, and what are you going to do for pain?
I mean, what are you going to do if you can find other ways to deal with it?
You would be better.
Even if you have an ability to cut that out, you know, cut it way down.
I would certainly be doing Castro packs over your liver.
I'd certainly be considering doing coffee animals to help your liver.
You want to keep your liver aligned.
Okay, so really super important.
One of the things you can do for pain, other than Tylenol, that is a struggle.
And I feel your pain because there's not a whole lot of natural solutions for it.
CBD can be beneficial for some people.
THC, which is the psychoactive form of marijuana, has this problem of your best bet.
It's legal and just about every state now, you could get it in liquid form,
tablet form, gummy form, that can be extremely beneficial.
It does make you loopy, maybe that at least can get you through the night.
You have to only take Tylenol during the day.
Maybe you'd be cutting way down, take a high dose of THC at night,
it will certainly help you sleep, and it will probably help you with the pain.
And it can help kill cancer.
So look at THC, just about every state has dispensaries for that.
You could buy it online if your state doesn't have dispensaries for that.
Start at a lower milligram dose, like 2.5 to 5 milligrams, and slowly work up.
It is to your pain relief.
Know that the side effect is going to make you feel loopy.
It's going to make you feel drowsy.
You're going to feel a little shy.
I hate the way it makes me feel.
I've never smoked marijuana or taken drugs in my life.
So I mean, I would do that versus having to take Tylenol in a regular race,
so I would try to do some other things.